minute bryzgalow leute was geht ab und
willkommen bei einem neuen video hier
mal wieder auf meinem kanal und so und
zwar habe hier in letzter zeit schon mal
so ein paar videos gemacht da ging es
einfach mal so um fünf dinge die jeder
schüler kennt oder dinge die uns in der
schule passiert sind oder irgendeinen
scheiß halt und da hab ich mir gedacht
komm du machst jetzt einfach direkt
nochmal so ein cooles video oder ich
hoffe cooles video und zwar geht es halt
einfach mal um fünf dinge die jeder
schüler hast und ich will jetzt
natürlich auch gar nicht lange lagern
bei mir aufgefallen ist dass ich sonst
immer relativ lange lava und ich würde
sagen wir fangen direkt an ich hoffe ihr
könnt euch mit mindestens drei oder vier
von fünf ding selber identifizieren also
schreib doch mal in die kommentare
welche sachen euch so extrem aufregend
an der schule und in der schule und ja
wenn euch das video gefällt dann sei
jetzt schon mal gebt einfach meine
daumen nach oben und ansonsten wünsche
ich euch jetzt ganz viel spaß so und ich
würde sagen wir fangen an mit nummer
eins
so war der unterschied ist natürlich
erst dann beendet wenn ich ihn auch
beendet habe als hausaufgabe macht ihren
bitte zu hause auf der seite im 93
ansonsten wünschen einen angenehmen tag
und auch ein brillantes wochenende mit
den ganzen aufgaben die ich euch jetzt
die aufgegeben habe viel spaß nummer 23
mein lieber freund das handy heute
nichts weil ein kleiner und cops in vier
jahren zum deck daher kann sie ab und
pizza dann kommen wir auch schon zur
nummer vier
ich wünsche euch einen einfachen grund
morgen liebe schüler und schülerinnen
hier haben wunderschöne unterrichts
starte wieder nach den ferien am
sonnigen montag wie kann es besser
beginnen
leider muss ich euch was die klausel
angeht etwas enttäuschend die konnte ich
über die ferien nicht korrigieren da ich
wie jeder von euch weiß auf meine
eigenen ferien habe aber kombiniert man
zum hauptsächlichen nämlich der aufgabe
die ich euch über die ferien erteilt
habe
dennis lügst du bitte anfangen und zum
schluss die nummer fünf wie oft muss ich
euch dann bitte noch darauf hinweisen
dass kaugummikauen in meinem unterricht
streng sind und er sagt es das wird
konsequenzen haben
leute was geht ab ich bin heute mal so
ein bisschen unterwegs in moss modus wir
schon gesehen und ein spaß aber auf
jeden fall sind wir jetzt natürlich auch
schon wieder am ende des videos und hier
unten links könnt jetzt mein letztes
video abchecken
dort ging es um so ein paar kleine
auffälligkeiten von justin bieber und
juden rechts mit meinem nicht vorletzten
video da ging es einfach noch mal oder
hier geht's noch mal zum video mit
meiner freundin das war dieser boyfriend
eck oder wie auch immer der heißt auf
jeden fall wenn ihr nichts mehr
verpassen wollte abonniert einfach den
kanal gibt armut verdacht das video
gefallen hat soll jetzt einfach noch mal
instagram lang war alles und in der
video beschreibung und wir sehen uns
dann am nächsten wochenende wieder ich
wünsche euch noch ein traumhaftes
wochenende und johanna reine show